the home opener on this tuesday night so
sit back and enjoy
we're going to enjoy it and those people
clearly are
enjoying it as well on the hill tonight
for the giants opening up their home
season will be the veteran jeff samaria
and he taps this one to crawford
crawford on the move
and that's how this game gets started
[Applause]
hits this one out to right moving back
is jalen davis
now he settles underneath it two outs
big chopper wilmer flores
to sandoval and a nice inning for
samaritan zach davies on the hill
tonight for the padres
glad to have this kid in the brown zach
davies as a brewer
he had a really good year ten and seven
three five five acquired in the off
season
curveball slider cutter change
yashrenski loops it into right
and on the first pitch the giants have a
base runner to start out the bottom of
the first
this one is on the ground softly and off
the hill is davies to flip to first base
for the out as jastremski moves into
scoring position
up to second base on the ground on the
ground bass machado
and it may have been that machado got a
knuckleball and now they're going to
wave in yasrimski
here's the throw no throw and the giants
are on the board
is on that particular play everybody
kicked it around
this one lifted in the air to left
center field grisham the center fielder
takes charge
a little back pedal but he makes the
catch and back to the bag at second goes
flores with now
two down georgia already taken over for
him in philadelphia this one has popped
up shallow right
out goes profar and he'll make the catch
win played with it
two on nobody out and here is naylor
may be playable for flores
and down to his seat of his pants he
makes the catch
now fernando tatis jr for the second
time tonight
there's it's second behe at first one
away
and tatis drives this one to right field
down the line back goes davis at the
whoa that ball is gone
a three-run home run for fernando tatis
jr
and the padres take a 3-1 lead with one
swing of the bat
his first home run of the year for
fernando tatis jr
but eric on second two down and will
myers
first one to will is swung on and
absolutely belted to straight away
center field new dimensions old
dimensions doesn't matter
another home run for will myers a
two-run
shot and the padres add on here in the
fourth
5-1 san diego and jeff samarj's night
not going to last much longer alex
dickerson flight out to center first
time up and now sharply it's one to
first it's going to turn into two
a liner to hosmer he tags the bag and
just like that two outs
hosmer off the bag into the pocket step
on the pillow
two outs tonight it's been the long ball
that has done the damage
swing and a miss and davey strikes out
crawford strikeout number four for zach
davies
swing at a miss he had no chance on the
change-up it was terrific
oh zach davies you are so much fun to
watch bases are loaded with nobody out
and wilmer flores will come up
on the ground maybe a pair that's one
and it's not in time
so flores beats it out the giants pick
up a run
and moving to third is yustrinsky
this will pop it up mejia coming back
and foul ground has room and he makes
the catch
now first and third two down and here
comes tyler heinemann
and a bloop here in the center field for
a base hit from third comes just
he'll score and it's a two-run game it's
now five to three
flores moves up to second on the rbi
single by heinemann
trying to minimize the damage that is
strike three and on the corner how about
98 and
paint one down here in the seven how
about a fresco
hornets now 5-3
on the ground picked it first by hosmer
to second for one titan's back to first
double play
3-6-3 on the twin killing that ends the
seventh
represents a tying run here for the
giants
that is on the ground left side machado
to second for one on the first for two
around the horn they go for the inning
ending double play
kirby yates through a lot of pitches he
pitched saturday
he pitched sunday enter drew pomerance
and that's a check swing did he go they
check yes he did they ring him up for
out number one
shaking off hedgie once twice fastball
sit strike three call
that is strike three of the padres win
drew pomerance comes in and closes the
door
the padres win the first game of the
series in san francisco